premier jour d'occupation du théâtre
national populaire de villeurbanne
un nouveau lieu culturel qui vient
s'ajouter à la liste des établissements
investi dans toute la france
nous on met fonctionne le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui est pas trop et sensuelle
un coup de semonce qui tombe après la
rencontre ce jeudi entre les syndicats
du secteur et jean castex
la principale revendication reste la
même reprendre leurs activités
après des mois de fermeture on pense que
cette cette maladie un lac au vide
elle est amenée à durer et qu'il va
falloir qu'on apprenne à vivre avec
il faut que les arts et la culture
puisse exister parce que c'est vital qui
est voilà donc on peut pas rester sous
cloche
comme c'est comme tout c'est le cas que
non quoi qui est une expression assez
anxiogène
villeurbanne a suivi le bal initié par
le théâtre de l'odéon et dans la danse
ce dernier a aussi entraîné les
intermittents de l'emploi ce qu'on nomme
les permis tant qu'ils enchaînent
contrat très courts et périodes de
chômage et dont les médecins gravitent
autour des activités culturelles
ils ont rejoints dans leur lutte les
intermittents du spectacle outre la
réouverture
ils se retrouvent autour d'un leitmotiv
commun le retrait de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
aujourd'hui je suis en fin de droits
donc mes droits seront poursuivis tout
là que ça pendant toute la crise
sanitaire jusqu'à fin juin et massacres
au 1er juillet réforme de l'assurance
chômage avec
vraiment c'est nous ont massacrés sur le
calcul en fait au 1er juillet si le
gouvernement maintient c'est très fort
les montants des allocations chômage
tiendront également compte des jours non
travaillés résultats pour les principaux
concernés une indemnisation qui tire
vers le bas
jean castex et roselyne bachelot penser
à la suite de la réunion de jeudi avoir
sonné la fin de l'entracte
ils ont annoncé 20 millions d'euros
dettes supplémentaires et une mission en
cours afin d'étudier le dispositif de
l'année blanche un mécanisme qui permet
à ces travailleurs de bénéficier d'une
prolongation de leurs droits
d'indemnisation
jusqu'au 31 août 2000 21 mai les
occupants de l'odéon ne sont pas
satisfait par ces annonces qu'on ne
lâche rien on est toujours là vendredi
samedi dimanche lundi marni jusqu à ce
qu obtenir satisfaction sur nos
revendications qui sont absolument
légitime autant pour les intermittents
du spectacle pour les intermittents de
l'emploi même combat
bras de fer entre le gouvernement et des
acteurs de la culture qui s'annonce long
alors que l'inde il se tiendra en sommet
social crucial qui réunira organisations
patronales et syndicales